those whom Almighty God has predestined
to eternal life even before the creation
of the world and while they are still in
the toils of worldly cares and pursuits
he leads with unutterable mercy to the
principles of the perfect life and does
so in many ways that flow from the pure
spring of his clemency so - it seems
appropriate fast to set down in
compendious language the praiseworthy
record of a memorable man whose life has
been exemplary in our times and will
prove beneficial for us as we read and
reread it and will be of equal use and
profit to posterity with the grace of
God I shall tell how by happy adventures
a man called finden a skort frim
Leinster attained perfection of life
despite frequent torments and
temptations
now the sister of this man was taken
captive with other women by those
foreigners called Norse men when they
devastated far and wide in the Scottish
island called Ireland then their father
ordered his son Finn 'dom to ransom her
and bring her back to him burning to
perform his father's orders and guarding
his sister's love in a faithful heart he
gathered companions around him and set
off with an interpreter but early on the
journey he was captured by pagans thrown
into Chains and carried without delay to
their ships which were moored at a beach
nearby all that day and the following
night he suffered in his fetters without
food or drink in the morning the norse
men held the council at which the more
sensible of them inspired in their
humanity by God we believe argued that
men who had come to ransom others ought
not themselves to be held by force and
this is how finden was set free for our
Blessed Lord recognized that his servant
though still a layman would serve him in
the future most devoutly in every way so
- on another occasion when a crowd of
the same enemies had chased him fleeing
into a house none of them were able to
find him hidden behind the door though
they searched for him in every corner
[Music]
now we think should we be silent about
the circumstances of his undertaken a
foreign journey or about the laudable
manner in which he attempted to conclude
it in the province of Leinster serious
dissension arose between two chieftains
the father of the finden who is our
subject was a soldier of one of the
chieftains and he killed the man of the
opposing party the opposing chieftain
overcome with anger advanced on the home
of Finland's father accompanied by a
large force with the intention
of destroying the man and his
possessions with fire and sword they
arrived by night and placed an armed
cordon around the house they set fire to
the roof and murdered Finn Dan's father
as he emerged from the flames finden was
lodged in another house and they started
fires around him in the same way but
could not lay hands on him so valiant
was his defence with the protection of
divine grace he eluded both the flames
and his enemies with scarcely a wound
his brother was in the same house and
they killed him not surprisingly the
event caused fierce emnity and
inexorable feuding between the tribes
before long however through the
intermediacy of some trustworthy men
finden and his people were given a large
sum of money and peace was restored
between the two sides in the very same
year Finland's enemies began to fear
that grief for his father would quicken
again in his heart and that he would
take revenge upon them equally they
wished to do away with him and were
hatching secret plots to this end they
put their plan into action by preparing
a seaside banquet for Finland Finland
was invited but Norseman arrived in the
middle of the feasting by prior
agreement with his enemies and seized
him they bound him tightly and
immediately made off with him
[Music]
as was offered the case his Norse Lord
unwilling to return home yet sold them
on to another who sold one to a third
and third to fourth
this last wanted to see his homeland
again so gathering his companions
together he led finden and some others
into captivity
when they had reached the midpoint of
their sea journey the Norseman chance to
encounter another Norse fleet one of
these people boarded the ship where
Finland was a captive and started asking
about the nature of the island and how
they fared there on board the ship
however was a man whose brother had been
killed by the questioner who was no
sooner recognized than killed as soon as
his companions saw this they got ready
for battle and the two ships engaged in
a long bitter fight while the struggle
was raging finden wishing to support his
master his companions got to his feet
despite his shackles the crews of the
other ships intervened and separated the
combatants finden shipped backed out of
danger Finland's master was mindful of
the loyalty finden had shown despite
being in shackles
wishing to reward such faithfulness he
immediately released finden from his
chains finden showed promise of bringing
blessings to him in the future after
that they reached some islands called
the Orkneys close to the Pictish race
they disembarked to refresh themselves
as they awaited a favorable wind they
wandered here and there around the
islands
when finden saw how free and easiest
captors were he began to explore the
island wandering anxiously how to get
away safely in a lonely area he found a
huge rock and attempted to hide behind
it but the rising tide usually reached
the rocket and finden was at a loss as
to where he should go or what he should
do on one side the sea threatened and on
the other fear of his enemies tormented
him as they ran about the island and
even walked on the rock where he was
hidden calling his name from all sides
he preferred to endure the wild sea
rather than fall into the hands of men
whose savagery outstripped that of
monstrous beasts those starving
he made light of the massive waves and
remained in the same place all that day
and the following night next day his
enemies stayed in another part of the
island and the force of the sea
diminished no longer reaching the
threshold of his refuge though sometimes
driven by the wind it surged right into
his cave so finden arose and fearing the
heathens crept cautiously through the
scrub in search of an escape route he
thought too that the land around him had
human inhabitants
which in the end of the island however
he discovered that on one side lay the
vast sea while the other side was
indented by a shallow bay robbed of his
physical strength and overcome by the
terrible weakness brought on by
imprisonment and hunger finden did not
dare entrust himself to the sea with
redoubled efforts he scoured the island
for three days on end subsisting on
herds and water as he sought a way to
get off and so he remained there until
on the third day he saw sea monsters and
huge dolphins playing and diving close
to the shore overcome by divine mercy he
contemplated these creatures with an
untroubled mind and poured out these
tearful prayers from the bottom of his
heart God creator both of these brute
beasts and of me a human being you gave
them the sea as their elements and to me
you gave the earth on which I set my
feet as is your merciful custom help me
in my present troubles from this moment
I dedicate my service to you in body and
soul and I shall never think again of
the enticements of this world I shall
seek you in the dwellings of the
Apostles
I shall journey into exile I shall never
return to my homeland from this moment I
shall serve you with all my strength and
follow you without a backward glance
fortified by this strong faith he
plunged fully dressed into the sea and
what I shall relate now is miraculous
instantly divine mercy made his clothing
rigid so that its support kept him from
sinking it seemed to him that his
clothes swam and bore him safely to land
through the swollen waves he climbed to
the hilltops looking for houses or smoke
rising from the house roofs for two days
he lived on a scanty diet of vegetation
for the dawn of the third day he saw
people walking about in the distance
though he had no idea who they were his
heart left within him and he went up to
them without hesitation they welcomed
him and took him to the bishop of the
neighboring community this bishop had
studied his letters in Ireland and had a
good knowledge of the language finden
stayed two years receiving many
kindnesses from this humane and generous
man
[Music]
you
[Music]